[Music]
what everybody lef koma in here and it's
gonna be a different vibe because this
is a special bonus episode the podcast
and I'm with a special bonus kind of
human and his name is Ryan holiday he
his work is something that I've followed
for a very long time his books our
bestsellers all across the world
translated into tons of different
languages and I didn't realize that
today with your book being officially
released you were completing the Trinity
I didn't know there was a Trinity
happening I we've we've had you on
before to talk about obstacles the way
in our NFL world its swept through the
league the Patriots the Seahawks all
these teams were reading it about
overcoming obstacles then you came out
with ego as the enemy we talked about
Nick Saban and Bill Belichick always
finding a way to bring it back and now
the last one stillness is the key which
I just reread today
and you brought me a little gift and I
appreciated a ring and inside it says
you could leave life right now Ryan
holiday thanks for having me I'm excited
to have this special bonus episode mean
not as good as a regular episode and
we're calling it a bonus episode is it
actually some sort of bonus no it means
that like they're gonna wake up and go
an episode on a Saturday holy [ __ ] this
is awesome all right
the 33% I posted that I was reading your
book today and like four people hit me
up and so they already pre-ordered it oh
man I was like let's go thank uh it's so
funny to me because when I look at all
your titles obstacles the way ego is the
enemy stillness is the key duh it makes
sense yeah when you were writing the
first one was this always plan to be a
three-part no actually it was I was
thinking about it today because it is
the sort of the close of it I started
the first one in New York in 2012
thinking I was going to write about
ancient philosophy mostly applied to
business was not at all thinking that it
would lead to talking to NFL teams that
players would talk about
that I've got to do some of the cool
stuff I've done in sports and I had no
idea what book would come after each one
so it's just kind of a it's just been a
cool surprise yeah yeah I noticed a few
weeks ago or a few months ago in your
social that you were were you at the
Browns or was just the book at the broom
no no I see cuz I spoke to the brown I
spoke to the team during training camp
for the Browns and then I spoke to the
coaches at the training camp for the
Rams this year I also spoke this was the
weirdest crazy I spoke at the NFL owners
meeting Wow
which was unreal all right so take me
back because I have a nice relationship
with Sean McVeigh yeah what was your
reaction to meeting him what you think
well I'm I'm a huge Sean McVeigh fan
because he's the first coach of my of
our age group very true and so there's
just something about it where like
obviously I'm getting to know him he's a
very cool guy but I just be I'm so used
to coaches being like my dad or my
grandpa yeah you know and so like here
this is the first time sort of our
generation starting to and I think
sports tend
like obviously because you age quicker
in sports like sports are sort of the
sign of what's to come and so you know
I'm hoping we'll see a similar
revolution in other parts of society
where some of the old ways of doing
things will be replaced with maybe a
slightly newer way of doing things
oh but did you notice any difference
because of his age in the accepting of
your philosophies compared to older
coaches or older front office's no I
don't think so cuz cuz I've definitely
heard from coaches of all stripes but
but it is interesting that one of the
coolest parts about sports is that you
wouldn't expect they're sort of
relentless focus on self-improvement
generally not you think these would be
people who would be just obsessed with
with you know getting a tiny bit
stronger or discovering some microscopic
advantage on the football field but in
fact like they're all relentlessly
focused on sort of human optimization
generally knowing that it manifests
itself on the field so I
I think Shawn is just this like the
youngest version of that sure but I you
know I was I was actually thinking about
texting him I listened to the podcast I
just tell him oh yeah so save the text I
will but but like one of the things that
intimidates me about sports is when you
hear about the journeys that certain
coaches had to go on to become head
coaches like like 20 year yes epic
chance that like in like Southwest
Missouri's yeah yeah and and my career
has been the opposite of that as well
like I published my first book at 25
like I dropped out of college I had a
successful career before that and so
before I was an author and so I don't
know I don't know if I could do it that
way and I'd be curious if Sean feels
like he could do it that way I imagine
he could but like I don't know like if
you told me I had to be a starving
writer starving artists and my first
book would come out when I was 50 I
don't know if I would have done
something else I believe it was Winston
Churchill who said it was a fine journey
to do once yeah right yes in the book
yes it is but I don't know like I have a
certain admiration for people who've
been able to do that and it also fills
me with dread and that's what's so
interesting is so if you haven't read
Ryan holidays book any of his books
before you've talked about this on so
many podcasts and so many shows about
the way you research a book and how you
read tons of books every year and you
you have a note card system that you
learn from Robert Greene that allows you
to organize and create like that and
what I find to be so interesting about
it is you find these patterns right you
can find 50 people that were great that
took walks every day you can find 50
people that took naps every day and you
see how it impacts them and and for you
to have this sort of a meteoric rise
very early and so many of your stories
are about the troubling paths or people
realizing their potential at 50 or 60
years old there is that interesting
disconnect where it's hope for some
people and for other people it's this
longing for wanting that hardship yeah I
mean for someone who wrote about a book
about obstacles I feel like
have been very blessed right like I
think I mean part of what I was trying
to do in that book is talk about that
obstacles are not just you know losing
your arm or being you know born into
poverty obstacles are you wake up every
day and the world is not the way that
you want it to be right like the coach
doesn't want to play you your publishers
not giving you the marketing support
that you want right you get stuck in
traffic you know there's a bigger as
small as it is yeah there's like [ __ ] is
always happening and and I think what I
try to write about is how do you sort of
use that not be overwhelmed by it not be
sort of aggrieved to buy it but I do
feel fortunate that you know there
hasn't been this like sort of massive
adversity that I've had to go through
sometimes I think about what's coming at
the same time watching oh that that's
absolutely a possibility right but
that's what we accepted it is how it
goes but I think with you is the one
thing that I see in your life that I see
and all of the stories is a discipline
yeah and that is also I think defining
of of the billionaires that only NFL
teams to the millionaires that play on
them is discipline is the probably the
biggest deciding factor between success
and mediocrity well that was the
interesting thing about the owners
meeting because you like you're looking
out in the audience and so there's the
coaches and the GM some of you
recognized and then it's like 32
billionaires and they're all they all
looked like the same suit and they're
all no no they're all each one of them
is like their own cartoon version of the
you know like there's Jerry Jones on one
side and then there's like it's like
succession they're all of his kids and
then Schad calm with like a cartoon
mustache that looks like he might tie
someone to a railroad track yeah totally
right there's Stan Kroenke and then
there's your per se yeah and then then
there's what's what's um who's the owner
of the Raiders oh yeah
Mark Davis yeah so they're just so
they're all who they are and they all
obviously are great at what they do and
to some you know to varying degrees but
like just radically different and I
think what I what I do try to write
about my books is what what are those
commonalities between people like that
so you could look at a great artist you
could look at a great general you could
look at a great president you could look
at some military Conqueror
and what what what do they have in
common it's usually a set of practices
or habits and and some sometimes the the
habits that they share they could have
this habit and then the opposite habit
in some other part of their life but I
do tend to look for patterns and what I
think that's what I think makes the
books work I did self scouting of the
last two times I've interviewed you okay
what I realized was I mean II watched
film of yourself it's a little bit okay
actually what I did was I read your book
and then I took a walk because it talks
about the great the great thought you
can do just when you're doing a
repetitive action like walking out frees
your mind and what I realized was I was
very selfish okay I read your book and I
read all these great stories and then I
had follow-up questions but I was
selfish to two people I was selfish to
my audience and I was selfish to you
because you're here to talk about your
book okay and to get people excited
about it and I'm selfish to my audience
as though I'm not explaining to them the
best parts of the book and what I get so
much from your writing that I want them
to understand is these little anecdotes
especially in the sports world that I
consider myself an expert in this and I
didn't even know about Tiger Woods is
upbringing like I'm reading what you're
writing about Tiger Woods and what he
went through with his dad and I'm like I
want you to deliver this gift to them
and all those interviews I've done I did
it so this is I'm trying to be very self
aware like well I'll be I'll be
unselfish too cuz that my stuff on Tiger
Woods in the book there's the great new
biography of Tiger Woods yes was that
the army cation yes yes fantastic and
then there's this fantastic
ESPN piece about Tiger Woods that I used
also who I'm but but it comes up like
the Navy SEAL training and all the stuff
that he did it's unreal because I read
that night I always thought that Tiger
had a bad back and we would joke oh it's
because of that Thanksgiving Day
accident or who's because when you play
golf there's a lot of twists and turns
but reading about Tiger Woods his
relationship with his dad yeah and and
sitting there in a high chair watching
his dad taking thousands of swings and
seeing his dad on the road and all of
his actions it
it painted that picture for me so much
more closer crystal-clear I ever
realized well it is interesting because
I think we've when when the story was
coming out we thought about it as like
oh this is what it takes to be great and
in in David Epsons new book he talks
about like just what a myth the idea of
that sort of that that you have to pick
what your gonna be if they pick what
your kid is gonna be at - hmm and and
just sort of pound it into their head
that's really tigers actual great
weakness is that he's he was been so
myopically focused on golf his whole
life that that I think he did a lot of
damage to his body but also just
mentally that was not good but when when
you rip like with some distance and when
you're not getting it through a Nike
campaign but when you're not looking at
his childhood through the lens of a Nike
campaign you're like this was horribly
abusive this horribly horribly his dad I
I think his dad was probably a
psychopath I mean he like he went to
Vietnam he had some did some dark stuff
there he got a separate family might
have brought a wife back from from
Vietnam another airing and basically
didn't want another kid Tiger comes and
he sort of treats Tiger Woods as like a
science fair experiment right and the he
was like was he a green beret yeah
there's a pretty much raised tiger
through Green Beret training yeah he
basically subjected him to intense like
sort of deprivation and exposure all of
which made him really tough on the golf
course but a miserable human being I
mean even that story of like okay Tiger
Woods would watch his dad play golf in
the garage if you have a kid you're like
what like you don't just strap your kid
into a chair for hours while you play
golf in front you don't even want your
kid in the garage you're like this
there's chemicals it's like yeah this is
not what you do and so it's it's cute
and quaint that Tiger Woods started
golfing so early and that he was on the
Mike Douglas show putting it two and a
half but you're also like wait that's
not good for him and so it ended like
his dad would would cheat when they
would golf together his
would yell racist slurs at him would try
to you know distract would do these
things it was like he was trying to make
him not a human being hmm and in a way
that's kind of what happened and and so
it made him fantastic at golf
but fantastic only at golf yeah and the
rest of the human stuff that's necessary
to balance out extreme success like that
I think eventually made him extremely
vulnerable and and we saw what happened
I feel because I got a chance to meet
Tiger last Thanksgiving at the match and
when I first felt his energy I was
completely taken aback because you hear
these stories but I'm leading a press
conference and he walks out and I had
never seen a human walk that stiff or
make so little eye contact with anybody
and be so centrally focused on doing
what needs to be done than leaving and
I've joked about the story before where
I had to also do a little interview
after Phil Mickelson beat him for nine
million dollars yeah and they came out
and I said Tiger hate to do this but
Phil just whooped your ass yeah I had a
little bit to drink and afterwards he
looked at me and he goes I enjoyed it
and walked away and Phil goes robot Phil
goes I've never heard him say that and I
believe that he softened up a little bit
after he won the Masters that moment
with his kid was there it really was
beautiful yeah from what you've read
about all these people with insane
driver and sake work ethic can it can
they chip away at that and gain some of
the human backer I think so I think so
or at least I hope so right you know
because I don't think I would wish that
permanent state on anyone but it is it
sort of endemic to the champion mindset
like what it takes to so relentlessly
want to get better to never be satisfied
with what you have done to be driven to
be the absolute best it does make it
impossible for you to enjoy what you
have and so it's kind of a paradox and
so like obviously Tiger Woods is the
best golfer in the history of the game
but would you rather be Tiger Woods or
Phil Mickelson you know and so like look
Elon Musk
hugely important for Humanity would you
want to be Elan musk it's a lot of
pressure it's just a lot of pressure it
doesn't seem fun like you know even if
you reach the moon someone's like yeah
you're gonna get to Mars though like
well and and you know it's like the
Donald Trump thing where he says like
you're gonna be so tired of winning it
kind of seems like winning sucks like at
that at that extreme level so when we
talk about Tom Brady yeah cuz Tom Brady
I think these last few years we marvel
at his process yeah marvel at his
discipline and how he doesn't eat
nightshades yeah tomatoes yeah and and
we see that he wins a bill belichick
wins the Super Bowl and it's it's do
your job and he's back at the office the
next day and yeah we've talked about
stories about Jerry Rice winning the
Super Bowl and he's practicing the next
day are they enjoying it do they ever
have a moment I think it depends I think
it depends I think there's kind of a
right way to do it in a wrong way to do
it
what I what I've heard about saving for
instance is that saving is actually
better to be in the locker room with
when you've lost the national
championship than when you've won one
that's that he says when you lose he's
like this is on me you did a great job
like we'll be back next year when when
he wins he's like well let's get back at
it you know what I mean oh that's so
deflating to hear from a team that like
poured everything into this where he's
thinking we didn't do it as well as we
could have could have won 63 210 yeah
yeah and so so there is an element of
that and I have that too I mean like I'm
sitting here I got a book coming out
today and I also have a proposal out for
like my next for right like and I was
writing this morning like so I there is
a there's an element of it that's
compulsive but there's also an element
of it that's pure and authentic that
loves the work and you gotta you you
always got to be thinking about why are
you doing it for the compulsive-like
sort of broken reason like if I do this
my dad will be proud of me you know if I
do this oh I'll be so rich they can't
laugh at me those are bad reasons if
you're doing it because you if Saban is
leaving the celebration because he
genuinely loves the rush of recruiting
yes that's good if it's because chasing
some
yes running from something yes it that
that's a very different so it's it all
depends on where they're coming from so
I I think and I talk in the story
there's this exchange between Joseph
Heller and Kurt Vonnegut to the clay
writers of the 20th century and they're
at this party with this billionaire I
think this applies the sports and and
Vonnegut sort of making fun of Joseph
Heller just fellow wrote catch-22 and he
says you know how does it feel that this
billionaire made more money this week
than your book will make in a lifetime
and he says I have something that this
guy doesn't have and he's like what
could that possibly be in Heller says I
have a sense of enough and and I I like
that I like the the cleverness of the
quip
but I also love when you think about it
Heller didn't stop at catch-22 he wrote
a bunch of other books they were
bestsellers like but he wasn't coming at
it from a place of now that was [ __ ] and
I still have to prove myself so to me
it's like can you can you strive to be
better can you love the the process but
can you love it from a good place
rather than a dark place and I think the
vast majority of Tiger Woods's career it
came from a dark place I was just gonna
say I loved how you showed the curse
word in the woods family was the word
enough yeah yeah it meant to submit yeah
give up and then I'm looking in the
second part and and his book your book
is broken down into mine spirit and body
yeah and so in mind we're hearing this
is about toughening the mind never say
enough but then in spirit it was you
need to understand that enough is enough
yeah and I love the showing of if you if
you live that way you'll never be
satisfied ever yeah there's a Tiger
Woods interview on Charlie Rose this is
like after all the [ __ ] yeah and and
Charlie what Charlie Rose goes like you
know what would you miss the winning or
say it says and he goes winning is good
but beating people is always better and
and that's that's so awful you know
that's so sad and I like I I don't mean
to be condescending I just like if
that's what your parents taught you like
that was horrible that was a horrible
thing for them
teach you and there's something his mom
said something to him when she was like
if you ever you will never embarrass me
because if you will beat you yeah not
like you won't do bad things because
you're a good person
yeah but it was like appearance so I
feel like I've what I saw in that
masters win is that's what he wanted
right as the Masters yeah that moment
where he's hugging this kid afterwards
and I I felt that was a that was a win
from a different place and I think it
has to me I think that's why it felt so
special I think but I also I don't think
he could have endured those 10 years
from the dark place like because what it
needs is it needs the winning and the
domination as the fuel to keep going and
that clearly see there was some deeper I
think pure he he was so not Tiger Woods
for so long yeah and he stayed at it it
could that to me that's a pure better
place when I was talking about Brady
before in the discipline and you have a
story later in the book about schedules
and routines yeah I for someone for a
long time who subscribe to the notion
screw routine yeah you're getting stuck
into repetitive action I'm gonna take a
different way home from work every day
and then when you look at the most
successful people yeah and you see that
those routine allows you the freedom
like what I loved is that I never knew
Russell Westbrook eats a peanut butter
and jellies what is it what does he do
he has the same peanut butter and jelly
sandwich every game I went to a Thunder
game not that long ago they sent me like
one of them is pretty great but he eats
it this is a mix minutes in 17 seconds
before the game starts every game but he
doesn't just eat a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich has to be cut a certain
way which is the right way to do this of
course like in a heart shape or
something but you want he wants to cut a
certain way in a certain kind of bread
with a certain kind of ingredients
strawberry jam I believe it was yeah I
heard when teams like really want him
because like peanut butter jelly
sandwiches are like nothing in the NBA
and like a lot of times the other the
the home team has to like provide the
stuff and so like when they really want
to like mess with the team they'll send
like I'm
Stables because it's like that worse
than before or like one of those
containers with peanut butter and jelly
in it together it's just a great idea
but probably know what you want but yes
so uh but the routine of the discipline
yeah and look I actually like the idea
of taking a different way home from work
there's there could be variety I don't
think that's necessarily antithetical to
routine the point is you've got to
reduce the amount of pointless decisions
that you make in your life and you got
to reduce the amount of sort of like
moral quandary that you like do I do
this do I do that
because there's an unlimited amount of
stuff you can do and the more successful
you become the more like I I was reading
the Belichick biography and it was like
it's interesting Belichick has like
basically never done an endorsement or a
television commercial and if you think
about it I mean maybe there's been one
or two small ones but he could mail
Belichick and I like Maalox he could
make tens of millions of dollars he
supported a brand that yet the what it
would give to that brand would be
unbelievable but what at what cost would
that come to the focus of so that the
the idea like if you think about the day
I don't do endorsements versus I do some
endorsements even though it's not if
maybe it's one or two years now you have
to think about whether you like I I have
deliberately not done an interview
podcast even though I've gotten lots of
interesting offers yeah because I've
seen the cost that it comes to other
writers that I know and not that I'm
like judging their decision are you
doing this then no no I don't have my
own Oh gotcha I mean I don't have my own
that would take you away from what you
actually want to do like what's the and
this is the the Rams at one of their
slogans is like keep the main thing the
main thing
yeah and so if you if you go this is my
main thing but I also do all these other
things and I or at least think about
doing all these other things that can
come at the cost of that it's not just
the cost of like okay I'm have to spend
a day filming this Toyota commercial
right it's now I have to think about
these offers for these 50 commercials
and then I have to see it's the whole
process of the the distraction self
question okay there was a part in the
body section where you were writing
about you know the the overvaluing of
stuff yeah and you also said you know
that a photo isn't the memory and and
you said you know if you fall in love
and anguilla and then you get married
was that about me
since I proposed in Anguilla did you
really I didn't I didn't you can tell
every wonder if I was if I'm Selma and
just leastways I think you saw an
Instagram post and went yeah I I I did I
did not think of that consciously but
but perhaps I did um I think in addition
to like the Tiger Woods stories that
were great I think that the the baseball
story about my fellow Jew Shawn green
was great because I remember him going
six for six with seven RBIs and having
that run and I did not realize that he
was in a hitting slump before and I'd
love for you to share that mindset of
what he went through cuz I think a lot
of my listeners have moments of that in
their lives
yeah in mid-2002 Shawn green is in the
worst slump of his career he's just
signed a huge contract with the Dodgers
and they're basically thinking of
trading him sending them down to the
minors benching him whatever and what
tends to happen in slumps both from what
I've read about and then the performance
coaches that I've talked to it's it's
you become your own worst enemy because
now you're not present at the plate
you're thinking about the slump mm-hmm
and Yogi Berra quote it's perfect yeah
well think and hit at the same time and
it like physically that makes sense like
in terms of physics like you have 400
milliseconds per swing at a pitch 400
milliseconds yeah you cannot be thinking
about anything that's what Brian
Westbrook who's one of my co-hosts I was
saying is I can I can look and see if a
guy gets it or not because I'm not going
oh I need to lean this way to get a
defender you either have that ability to
do it or you think too much
it's this single hardest act in all of
sports I'm hitting a baseball hitting a
baseball it it it
it's on the line of straight up defying
physics like we don't really quite
understand how they're able to do
because you technically have to decide
and begin swinging before the balls
really left their hands and and that's
why I like the best who's ever done it
is like at 400
that means he's missing six out of ten
times this is insane so what Shawn green
does is the opposite of what most
players do well it there's an
interesting story and he tells it in
he wrote a fascinating book which you
would like called the way of baseball
okay but but basically not only was he
in his slump but like his coach hated
him and he was like sort of barred from
batting practice and so he had to do a
lot and this I may be pushing some stuff
together slump was like a virus don't
bring it around the yeah people he so he
did most of his practicing on a tee like
he was like playing t-ball and and so
what he realizes he's like I have to
like wipe this can't think about any of
this and so this is sort of one of you
starts picking up Zen Buddhism he starts
meditating and and basically he comes to
the idea of like look I have to be
totally and utterly present at the mount
I can't be thinking about the streak I
can't be thinking about what I'm gonna
do I can't be thinking about anything I
have to be totally there and so it's
this I you know he would repeat to
himself a chop chop wood carry water
chop wood carry ax it's about pushing
the mind so you emptying the mind sounds
bad it sounds like the absence of
thought but really it's making room for
this sort of subconscious thought and
the muscle memory to do what they do and
he's able to get it he comes out of the
slump basically with this maybe top 15
performances in all of baseball it's six
home runs in one game like one Grand
Slam crazy and then and then he hits
like the next like three four days he's
still on the streak it's just he works
himself to whatever the best place you
could possibly be and that place is so
fleeting it only lasts for like three or
four games felt like it defines a life
it defines a career and so how do you
get there whether you're a movie
producer or a podcaster or writer or I
mean look guys not far from here on Wall
Street a single day of that level of
concentration and focus could make a
fortune that last generations you know
like it's we think these moments don't
matter but they do matter and and the
idea that you're gonna bring anything
less than all of yourself to it in a way
is like very arrogant like that it's
like oh I'm gonna be giving a talk today
but I'm also just me texting on my phone
like right up until I go on my yeah not
how it works it was because you you
wrote a lot about you know sitting in
stillness even if it's like the five
minutes before you go on yeah
allowing the silence to kind of creep in
and my fiance does a lot of dance so
when you kept putting Twyla Tharp in the
book we talked about Twyla so much and
she was talking about you know it's like
I don't even know if this is right
phrase but like healthy loneliness or
something like that and and a lot of
people especially in today's age and we
love to do this and talk about it
people's obsession with their cell
phones but we do not sit alone I went to
a float tank recently and I went in
there and I went into the lobby I'm
about to go on my phone and check
Twitter yeah and it says on there please
do not use your phones yeah and there's
three dudes sitting there on their
phones look at nono looking at the walls
looking at the ceiling I'm walking over
I'm reading pamphlets and it's so funny
because we are electing to enter a Dark
Void world of silence but I'll see you
till then yeah up until then I gotta
cram it all and when really I can get in
the right mindset now but what I liked
about that what the Shawn green stuff
was he's four for four yeah and now he
can go I'm not in a slump anymore yes
and he can go out there and go how do I
keep doing what I'm doing but instead he
kept going chop wood carry water yeah
and he was able to sit in that beautiful
flow and and sit in the stillness and
and to bring him back to Belichick
there's this story about the the sate
the Seahawks Patriots Super Bowl yeah
we're with like a minute left
Belichick looks over and he sees the
panic on the Seattle sideline and he
sees Pete Carroll running up and down
and what's incredible because this was
in Michael Marty
book about the Bell in his book about
coaching gridiron genius he was saying
that in the before the year started
balichek was working on defenses in the
red zone because the year before they
were so bad and and we can marvel at the
fact that it culminated in the Super
Bowl which is just the most Patriots
Belichick thing ever but of course
because that's how he operates
but I've always heard that story and
didn't believe it a little bit because I
thought this is the Super Bowl yeah I've
been to a few I know the madness that's
going on I still understand don't
understand how coaches with forty
seconds can process what the other teams
gonna do who's out there for them I'm
looking at the commercials yeah and it
made sense to me when I read your book
about him being in the stillness and not
being overwhelmed by sensory what did
you it cuz he was just asked about this
they're like oh are you looking at
analytics he was like I'm looking at
analytics less than zero times and I
think people took the wrong thing from
that because clearly he is obsessed with
math and the organization is is built
around math but the point is he the math
it's like the math a year before said
they weren't good in the goal line you
know that goal line play so he practiced
it to such a point so when he is sitting
there on the sidelines and the game is
on the the game is on the line he's not
thinking about anything he just knows
right it just comes naturally do you
believe he's photographic memory like I
don't know I don't know but I think I
think you want it you want to get to a
place where you're so prepared we're so
in your rhythm that it just it just take
it just takes over there's a great Twyla
Tharp thing she was talking about we
were talking about routines she's
talking about like every day she she
goes to her studio she does like 45
minutes of this it's just like routine
she does every day she's like the
routine is the the the routine is the
winning is not like me working out at
the gym the winning is when I get in the
cab to go to the gym she's like as long
as I just get myself out of the house
and then start the process it takes over
that's like what David Goggin says all
the time where he's like just get up and
[ __ ] run now yeah he says it
a lot more motivating but yeah just the
the start of the action is the success
yeah and so you what you do is you go
back further and further from the action
to the the little actions james clear
calls them like atomic habits the little
one he's literally read that book
recently yeah the example that i gift
everybody is the ice cube at 32° yeah
when it's frozen at 25 yeah and nobody
talks about it moving from 25 to 29 but
we all want to talk about when it goes
from 31 to 32 and it starts sweat yeah
so it's all about the little things the
that precede the outcome and so that
decision on that goal line is from a
year of practice and it ensues
so i got a copy of this book again
stillness is the key a few months ago
and there was very early a story that my
producer Ingmar has heard many times
I've sent it to leaders in this and it's
the notion of inputs and Napoleon yeah
we live in a world right now I have a
lot of alerts on my phone yeah cuz I run
a lot of social media accounts and all
that stuff and I'm trying to keep up
with it and we have this notion today
that to be successful you must be
ever-present yeah but when I read about
Napoleon and how he would tell his
secretary if something comes wait three
weeks to give it to me because it will
likely sort itself out I experience
those moments all the time now that like
you've shown that to my brain and this
generation I think more than any really
needs to know about that yeah so
Napoleon's thing was I'm not don't give
me information or requests in real time
he's like look if it's really bad news
like wake me at me that is traffic yeah
that's what I need but don't wake me up
with good news cuz like I don't really
need to know it doesn't change anything
and don't wake me up with trivial
requests that the passage of time is
going to likely resolve and so I what I
take from that is like so much of why we
feel overwhelmed is actually like not
the outside world its its artist I'll
give you an example so I get lots of
emails from fans it's wonderful
I but I can
this I can't if I kept up with them in
real time I never have time to write you
wouldn't accomplish anything and so what
I what I do is I I sort of star them I
mark them as read I star them and I
respond when I'm on planes like when I
was flying here yesterday
responding to like 20 of them or
whatever inevitably well sometimes I'll
respond like two months late three
months late yeah as the books have done
better the response time is lagged more
but invariably people will reply oh my
god I never thought you would reply
thank you so much even though I'm
replying like a one-sentence reply yeah
to some 500 word email two months later
they're like I never thought you would
reply thank you so much I'm not saying
that to show that I'm a great human
being what I'm saying is that they sent
me an email not expecting a reply and so
the guilt that I felt about not
responding fast enough is totally in my
own head you manufacture that and it's
like that with a lot of things people
feel like I need to know what's going on
in the world I need to follow the news
in real time I need to check my email in
real time that's why I have to I know
I'm supposed to be having dinner with my
family but like what if I got an email
from work you know and and the truth is
like almost nothing is more important
than whatever you're doing in that
moment and even if that thing is not
important and so it requires some
practice and discipline and I think
clear boundaries to decide you got to
decide when when you're gonna do it and
so like for me like I've had to more or
less stop using Twitter because I found
I can't really use it healthfully I feel
like the less when you did your whole
Trump thing with your dad yeah that was
like a separate thing that kind of blew
up knowing that you're also like a big
marketing guy I was like he probably
planned this whole thing and knew this
is the perfect way to go but I feel like
you probably this is a guess did you get
such a reaction that that sort of pushed
you off Twitter a little bit was
actually more and so I wrote this book a
couple years ago about Peter Thiel's
democracy and the really good you should
buy that thing the horribly nasty tweets
from terrible people in media mmm was so
gross that I was just like like actual
media people yeah just like you
you you were chronicling the the loss of
a big website with so many jobs that
people might want you just you just
realize that like there's this whole
generation of people that have been sort
of radicalized by social media some of
them politically yeah some of them just
sort of like with this weird this is
nasty
like meanness you know and it's just I
just don't think it's a super healthy
place to be like I still use it I try
but I try like I try not to I don't have
it on my phone I try not to use it in
real time yeah and I like it's great for
relationships like talking to people in
DMS it's like a great way to reach
people you'd otherwise have no way to do
but what I try not to do is any sort of
like scrolling through the feed because
it just I don't think it's good for
mental health no I don't think so either
but what I would do it but if I were you
even like you do have to use it for work
and I use it for work too
what I would say is you've got to delete
the alerts though you've got to get rid
of the alerts yeah because I like here's
what I do I just look at it and go like
what are 10 K give me see if you can
come up with 10 cases we're resetting
the alert and your response in real time
so I had a significant impact on pitches
to you so my only thing is I have found
that the ability to again this is gonna
sound very futile and welcome to a very
serious lights off experience I don't
know I did not plan this all the lights
just went off in the studio I have all
right so what Nick is looking into it
I would hope I'm gonna stop doing
interview Hey alright so the lowlights
literally just went off on their back on
if let's say bleach report posts a video
about football and I get an alert and I
comment within the first two minutes
based on the algorithms I go at the top
and I have found that it will lead to
like 30 or 40 followers so the effort of
growing accounts sure it has become
beneficial now we can have a very long
conversation about the actual benefit of
having followers well I would so I would
go yeah what's the what's the very real
ROI and then I would also say let's say
there is a very real
oh I like let's say it makes you $50,000
a year or some number can't you pay
someone to do it yeah you know what I
mean and so so so like I have Instagram
but it's on my wife's phone and so I use
it but I have to like get her phone so
it's like opt-in to like ask her to use
it to whole process yeah or I can just
send her a photo and say can you post
this she does post a love she does but
which has some costs cuz you should they
often goes through the filter but but
then I'm there's no temptation for me to
like mindlessly scroll or see other
stuff because that it's the it's the
loss of time and that's what I was
trying to explain to people Oh bleach
report with the whole idea of Napoleon
of limiting inputs you can't do any
worthwhile thought and you can't do any
worthwhile creation if you're constantly
trying to keep up with everything so
wait so how many followers you have I
think on Instagram it's like 17 or 18
and then the left go show account so
like 38 I mean the video one so you're
talking my Instagram I'm talking about
Twitter Instagram like okay so so you
get 40 followers a pop for four for
having your entire life be on call and
we're like your attention can be
interrupted at any moment oh I know the
content factory they post hundreds of
videos a day like that's what yeah man
you're gonna have a conversation later
because there was supposed to be but
we'll figure now in terms of though that
I want to get back to kind of the
stories like Jordan we're talking about
fuel yeah Jordan was so fueled by hate
and what's so funny is this wrong word I
would say anger and resentment but the
the Hall of Fame speech really kept I
think it really it did catch a lot of
people off-guard yeah and what it made
me realize is I had a poster of Jordan
in my room yeah and the quote on it was
I've missed thousands of shots in my
career and that's the reason I'm so
great and at first I was like what an
amazing like this guy's made all the
shots I remember I can't even visually
remember a video of him missing a shot
it's only the the elos shot and winning
and then the
the one against the Utah Jazz but then
you realize what is the [ __ ] what is the
point if even at this moment where you
get into the Hall of Fame you bring the
dude that beat you to get a roster spot
in high school and you still have to
show every imagine being angry at
someone who got a spot on the high
school just high school like just
anything and I still being angry and
you're Michael Jordan and then you go he
actually was better than you he was like
seven inches taller than Michael Jordan
like Jordan was 511 the kid was six
seven it's not like what are you what do
you what decision you now run an NBA
franchise right like what decision would
you have made that's in Santa have you
met a lot of people that have overcome
incredible obstacles and achieved a lot
and you just see they're still not happy
or they're still trying to chase
something yeah of course I mean look
it's a very common thing because the
anger is it's I would say it's eat drugs
and musicians to anger and successful
people mm-hmm you know what I mean it's
a like their there is this element I
think we all have it if wanting to prove
people wrong and so that's very powerful
fuel but it's also very combustible fuel
and it's it's also very corrosive fuel
and so I think you see it in that that
Hall of Fame speech it's not just that
he's angry at that guy to me the the
weirdest strangest part is when he
complains how much the tickets to the
dinner cost for his children and they're
like you sold a billion dollars or the
shoes this year you literally just
launched like a 500 million dollar
tequila company yeah and and so you
realize that what what it is is you go
okay I'm gonna prove these people wrong
so you have that anger and it works but
eventually it stops working and so what
the mind does it's like people have back
pain right you have back pain and that's
why you start taking opioids but then
the mind begins to create pain so you
continue to take opioids right that the
mind is creating things to be angry
about because it knows that's what you
need for fuel yeah and like Belichick
does this but I think Belichick I don't
think
check is walking around as an angry
person I think as a coach he goes what
can what can I find as a piece what can
I
I can't believe they said this about us
and he wants to use it for the team but
I don't think he's sincere you know what
I mean and that's the difference it's
like are you are you deciding to pick
something in this moment or is this
going to like the sort of core marrow of
your being that like it's you against
the world that's not that's not a place
that will allow you to enjoy the fruits
of whatever you end up accomplishing and
I think a lot of people convince
themselves much like a rocket ship that
the fuel is those boosters to get you
out of the atmosphere yeah and then once
I get there I'll drop my anger yeah and
I'll float freely in space and achieve
all that I've hoped and looked down at
earth and realize my place right when
they don't realize is they never dropped
the tanks know that yeah the tank and if
you don't drop them yeah you explode
yeah like if you don't drop them you're
in trouble yeah but it the problem is as
they go that's how I got here right this
is what I've based this is the reason
I'm successful and they cling to it and
I think it's very rare when like Arianna
Huffington was like that where she
probably was like sleep is for losers
I'll sleep when I'm dead yeah and then
she almost died and went oh no I need to
sleep yeah and you need almost that
cataclysmic realization you need like a
kind of a rock bottom and and from what
I have heard that's actually what that
Hall of Fame moment was for Jordan I've
heard really is that that for him the
analogy I heard it was just like he'd
stuffed this all in a closet over the
years and then it came exploding out and
everyone saw what was in there and he
saw what was in there and he was like I
don't like that so I'm hurt that's a
phenomenal yeah I've heard he's so super
competitive and still very soon but I've
heard that it's not as bad yeah because
it doesn't even need to explode out of
your closet but like if your friend came
over and happened to accidentally open
it and saw what was inside
oh very actually you live like this but
you'd but you don't realize it yeah
because everyone looks at their closet
and goes that's just my stuff yeah they
don't realize what it is totally we were
talking about this before with Ingmar
about archery and
Kenzo and letting it all go and if you
can kind of explain that and then I want
to equate it to one guy in sports right
now that I think is as sort of a cheat
what you're trying to do well so it is
interesting because the people who are
most obsessed with process in sports
have won the most like save and talks
about process he's the greatest legacy
and you know basically in college
football
Belichick same thing so it's funny that
in the rest of the world that's not how
people are always results focused right
like like whenever I hear an author tell
me how many copies of a book they want
to sell I'm like I'm I'm out because
because like first off you're feeling of
this company with like views yeah like
it's all [ __ ] it first I've it's
[ __ ] second it's we all know that
the best stuff doesn't necessarily have
the most views and the idea that that
you can actually realistically do
anything to get that goal it's
preposterous so like whenever someone I
remember someone is like oh I want to
sell two million copies and I was like
why two million copies no like oh I
heard you know Malcolm Gladwell sold 1.5
million copies of this book and it's
like so you just pull this number out of
your ass basically if you just decided
someone else had done X yes so you had
to do you know like 20 percent more than
X and that's such a crappy way to live
but it's also like shouldn't the goal be
to reach as many people as the book can
reach and and and shouldn't also the
goal be to write like the best possible
book and and which part do control
writing a great book or do you control
how many copies it sells so like we have
this what if you've read zen in the art
of archery he talks about this idea of
willful will and it's that it's the
archer who really intently is trying to
hit a bull's eye who will never hit them
because you your consciousness isn't
allowing room for the process to happen
and you're not focused on form your
folks it the better analogy since not
many people do archery anymore is golf
when you are trying really hard at golf
you are shitty at golf yeah you know
like if when you step up to the ball and
you're like I'm gonna hit this a mile
that's when it goes off yeah
yeah that's when you embarrass yourself
and and so we can see that in these sort
of isolated incidents and sports and
then we go right back to our life in the
way I'm gonna make a million dollars yes
or I'm gonna sell this company for a
fortune to Google and it's like no you
gotta say like I'm gonna do my best
yeah it's every coach in the beginning
of the season goes we're gonna win the
Super Bowl yeah you know the Tennessee
Titans don't go out there and go we're
going for seven and nine yeah look if
you really think about it now when Jeff
Fisher this is some hard knocks went up
there and says we're not gonna do this
eight and eight [ __ ] that was his
main focus and then they went four and
twelve because the goal was net it was
just we don't want to be average yeah
okay well you got your wish but it was
they were never building on it day to
day yeah but but in terms of the Kenzo
part about enjoying the process and it's
not about whether you hit the bull's eye
it's enjoying pulling back the arrow
yeah and when it goes and I really think
when I watch Patrick mahomes right now
I'm seeing an effortless
I'm seeing I'm not seeing someone that's
thinking every time he's upset on the
sidelines it's because the process
wasn't filled and literally a video came
out today which was him before the
87-yard or the 80 sees me 78 yard drive
on Sunday to win the game he stood there
and said just trust your teammates trust
the process and have faith and we're
gonna do it yeah and I don't I never see
him struggling I never see him thinking
too much the fact that he could this
happened on Sunday I doubt you saw it
there was one play where he's running
and he looks back at the referee and
keeps running and the announcers were
amazed that in the presence it was like
a fourth and eight the game was on the
line and he had the presence of mind to
look back to see if the ref had thrown a
flag and looked at the ref to be like
why didn't you throw a flag that the
game was so slow for him and it's
something we hear in sports all the time
slows down but mastery allows you that
of course and and and there's all these
things that lead up to it it's practice
it's loving the process it's eliminating
distractions it's managing your life
well so you have room for that and then
ultimately and that's
I think about Jordan it's like the great
moments in Jordan's career not when he's
trying to dominate spud Webb or or life
trying to humiliate someone it's it's
when he just loves it right like we're
the love of the game the great Jordan
moments are the moments when he just
when he's sticking his tongue out you
know like that were you run spy and goes
I don't know I'm just hot right now
like that's we all love yeah where it
comes so easy to them yes and and I
think I bet you've had moments in your
career where you were just like killing
it in an interview or something came to
you that didn't come from you going like
this interview it came from being loose
it came from having done the work up
until this point yeah came from it came
from a place of non thinking when you go
like you talk a lot about the routine
some people like up at 4:00 a.m. some
people work at 10:00 a.m. did any of the
routines remind you of your routine
whether it's ulysses s grant and did any
of the routines you go that would never
work for me but i understood why it
worked for them so i talked a lot about
Churchill's routine in it and
Churchill's routine is fascinating
because he has all these hilarious what
a life this man lived so one of his is
that spouses should never see each other
before noon which I actually like and
and the thing is him and his wife had an
incredible relationship yeah I guess
right but like so he and and for him it
was about like like there are different
zones in the day to do different things
there's a relaxation zone there's like
taking a bath zone a nap zone there's a
write a swan zone yeah and and so I just
love the idea that it's like you have
you have different things that you kind
of do every day I've tried to be a
little bit more flexible with my routine
especially having kids it's like the
idea like Russell Westbrook's routine
for instance now that he changes teams
is he like anxious you know like if so
if you're too I'm like if I'm so wedded
to my routine well what happens we have
to go to New York for a week you know it
I want to have routines plural that
allows me to be flexible so it's more
like I have a list of core things that I
do every day yeah and I kind of mix the
order around but like these are the sort
of touch stones that I can always come
out
tell you take a lot of pride when you're
traveling and you still get in like 4
miles in the pool yeah like I could tell
that that matters I've never done four
miles in the pool but yeah whatever it
is that you do yes I ran and swam today
and the thing that's the other part of
it when you love the process when you
love the routine like I today's the book
the book coming out so I could be
sitting there constantly refreshing
Amazon I could be making phone calls I
could be harassing by publisher what's
the numbers like a monster all this is
gonna have next to no impact on sales so
it's like it's like it's done you know
what I mean like I want it or lost it
already so like for me it was like I'm
gonna just have a good day I'm gonna
work out I'm gonna write like I was
writing in my hotel room I'm gonna like
try to eat well yeah I'm gonna try to
like be present I'm gonna like for me
it's there's no amount of anguish that's
gonna change where this freighter is
going so but what I do control is the
ability to have just another good day
that moves things forward on whatever
I'm doing next will your wife or anyone
close to you try to get you to celebrate
at all I mean I'm not saying I won't
celebrate how do you celebrate
I usually celebrate by working more but
no I mean I do try to appreciate the
moments but I think the other thing
that's that's that I was thinking about
this last night it's like I've done this
now nine times so you got to imagine the
other part for for Bella check or save
and not to compare myself to them you
just did it's okay no no like I
I can imagine he's leaving the party to
celebrate the championship early to
recruit because like first I was just a
[ __ ] party and he's been to this
party seven times already
yeah and it's not really about him it's
about everyone else and so that's the
other thing I kind of think about with
books is like I'm not in this to put out
books you know what I mean like I like
writing books yeah so that's what I
enjoyed about your book perennial seller
was the intent of creating and what it
is you're really trying to accomplish
because it's my number one issue with
with content today whether it's video or
audio or written word
that we're all trying to fill this gap
that we think people want and we're not
looking at what we believe needs to be
created where we letting this algorithm
decide who we are what we're gonna what
we're gonna do and the algorithm doesn't
[ __ ] know the algorithm only knows
what people have already liked exactly
it doesn't know what they don't haven't
even seen yet first a few notes that we
just want to get out before we kind of
wrap up is is non-sports people okay I
thought this quote from Tolstoy that you
featured love can exist off in the
future love is only real if it's
happening right now yeah is the number
one way to fix every relationship that's
ever experienced an issue yeah so many
of the issues that I always hear to go
very far from sports is you did
something to me in the past yep you're
not gonna give me something in the
future right but really the only way
that you'll ever connect with somebody
is truly just being there in that moment
yeah I would say like the the biggest
source of conflict in my relationships
is when something happens like somebody
lies to you or somebody talks to you a
certain way or somebody drops the ball
on something this could be a romantic
relationship or a professional
relationship or it could just be like
some stranger on the street sure is when
you go if I let this slide right now
they're gonna do this to me all the time
you know what like and it's like if no
idea like that's good like what are you
talking about and and you're not being
present when that happens though so like
like if you really think about it like
let's say somebody cheats on somebody
else in a relationship there's some pain
from the cheating but really what makes
the relationship unable to continue and
I'm not saying we should stay with
someone who cheats with you or that you
should cheat but it's it's the fear that
they will do this to you again and the
inability to repair that in the
relationship is the problem suffocating
and it's suffocating and it makes both
parties miserable and it's also
impossible to fix because you can't know
so if it's neither of you are being
present and and that's a you know
killing the relationship and then the
quote that I thought is something that
everyone deals with no matter what they
do from Martin Luther King jr. really
that there
a battle in all of us yeah between what
we can be and how hard it is to actually
get there yeah everyone listening to
this right now has a dream and I get
dozens of emails every week either
people wanting to do this because they
believe that this is their dream or they
have another dream and they just can't
muster up the courage to do it and the
thing that I think frustrates everybody
is no matter how many books they read or
how many podcast they listen to or how
many people they meet they know that the
way to get there is to just do it and
there there is no other way and I think
that's so scary to people and it's and
it frustrates them completely but once
they realize that all it takes is you
just doing the thing yeah your fear
should subside but but it is the number
one thing that I think arrests everybody
yeah he said we haven't he said and he
said this when this meant something that
you said there's a North and South in
every one of us and if these forces are
fighting with each other and you've got
to decide sort of what side you're gonna
be on but you talked to people they're
like yeah I want to be a writer and it's
like okay what have you written you know
it show me the writing or they're like I
want to drop out of college to start a
podcast or I want to you know quit my
job and become an entrepreneur and it's
like what what what makes you think you
could only start that stuff after and
the fact that you haven't started it now
out of love and passion and real
commitment to it is a sign that maybe
you don't have it you know what I mean
and so you should be you should be doing
it already and then you can talk about
what's the best way to do it or business
but it's like if you haven't started
that's saying something
you're waiting for a shot and this isn't
unlike sports you don't get drafted you
know what I mean there's there's no
other part in the world where they pick
you and say we're gonna make you into
what we need yeah I think people I've
always assumed it's because the college
selection process it's like that that
six months where you're getting all
these letters in the mail yeah and
they're like your scores quality of ID
you four Elizabethtown College
and everyone's like oh this is how life
works like people see what you can do
and that's never the case and I my
advice always sucks I'm like if you want
to do a podcast you need to start one
right if you want to be on camera use
your phone right you're you're not it
isn't there has never been an instance
where within three days a Fox executive
is gonna go I saw that Instagram post
you're coming on realize it's going to
be a journey and if you start it now
you'll get there that much faster no
totally totally I Seneca as this line he
says the one thing fools always have in
common is that they are always getting
ready to live like they're always about
to do it and they are right in the chest
totally and it I think there's something
that is a Gresham's law or I forget what
it's called but the idea is that it
always takes longer than you think even
when you take the law into account and
like the obstacles the way came out in
2014 it did okay first week
didn't get picked up by the Patriots
till the end of that season so that's
like six months didn't get written about
my Sports Illustrated for a year
didn't really really start selling until
after that it didn't hit the bestseller
list until May of this year it took five
years it rare is it for a book to do
that I mean I think there's some
shenanigans going on look it's it's
conspicuously absent on the bestseller
list but the point is like it it takes a
long [ __ ] time and then the other
thing to go to what we're talking about
with enough like you know how it felt
didn't feel like anything do you know
what I mean like like you get the news
and you go okay and then you get back to
work not because you're unhappy or
because it doesn't it's that it never
really had any power to change you it
doesn't mean anything like I was talking
about this with a coach friend of mine I
was like Kevin Durant wants to come to
New York to win a championship on his
own and you know how it's gonna feel
exactly the [ __ ] same like it's not
gonna feel any different yeah but the
the point is like it never had the power
to do anything and it was if you're
doing it right it was never wire
in the first place so you might as well
do what you want to do of course and and
realize that you know there's not gonna
be any award or any contract or anything
that's gonna go yes I've made it that
doesn't [ __ ] exist no it doesn't
doesn't exist they don't throw your
parade and even if they did he's gonna
end it wouldn't change anything yeah
yeah yeah all right
go and check out the book stillness is
the key if you want to check out if you
want to find a way to start off thinking
about whether it's stoic philosophy or
getting into a good mindset Ryan also
has a book called daily stoic where
there is a meditative passage that you
can read read every day and you can also
get a journal too and I have started
journaling a lot more lately just kind
of emptying the brain every is a podcast
of it too and if you want it digestible
in three to four minutes the daily stoic
podcast is a great way to do it Ryan I'm
very proud of you I know that means a
lot to you but thank you for this
congratulations on everything and love
you buddy
thanks man yeah bro all right people hit
him up I know you might not what is it
at Ryan holiday yeah hit him up on
social
I am the lef koe me and enjoy the games
tomorrow I'll hurt you guys later
[Music]